hi welcome to another week of my choice
for this week I wanted to look at some
of the games that I had in Gibraltar coz
Gibraltar tournament just ended and one
of the games that I really liked was
against Grand Master from Spain and
especially I kind of chose this game
because in the next hour in the game of
the week I'm gonna look at a game that
one cow played as white and the openings
are kind of similar so I thought it
would be nice to see what if this line
happened what if that line happened
so yeah let's let's dive in so
I put it in Gibraltar in 2017 and it was
it was a nice tournament I really liked
it I would recommend it I like to go
back again
I just have school so yeah this is
English opening and so the thing about
English opening is that there are so
many other ways that black can play or
white can not let black play so it's
kind of tricky it makes it's a good idea
for you to try and have a solid
variation against it's something that
you know that the ideas make sense and
that's what I try to do so I tried to
play this line and I do believe and it's
called something like four Knights
variation which to g3 I'm not entirely
sure why four Knights I'm assuming
because the Knights will come out of c3
and f3
but yeah so here is very common for
whites to try and play Knight c3 and
then black would get the chance to put
the knight on c6
and the idea is very simple this night
on b6 is going to kind of dominate the
Queen side and then later on you might
have ideas with a5 a4 given the chance
and your other night will go to c6 and
so those are the the general ideas so
you kind of want to put this light here
this bishop here make short castle
ideally have this bishop with each six
because it controls this long diagonal
and you might want to think about
something like a 5 depending on the
situation so these are the basic ideas
so Knight f3 is something that's very
common it's it is possible that's here
or earlier for white to play eatery and
try to do nice eat ooh and that's also
very interesting because then white
could have some ideas with d4 or f4 and
that night on each you isn't really
blocking the bishop so that's something
that's if you're thinking about this
opening is wise you could consider and
so Knight f3 knight c6 Castel so far
normal Bishop e7 rook b1 the idea of the
rook b1 is to my understanding to simply
try to play like a 3 before or looks to
be rook b1 is kind of preparing for a
push on the Queen side so a5 I thought
if I was pretty cool
because it kind of takes away the ideas
with a 3 B 4 I probably could have
played castle first but I didn't really
think it was that different and so here
we kind of reach this position and you
see white played rugby one here on Luke
8 and then I'll move 11 white put the
rook to c1 because it kind of makes
sense for the group to be and the C file
cuz rook on the C file Brooks kind of
like open files Dante they don't like to
be blocked by your own pawns so that's
why Roxy one was played f6 to simply
keep this pawn strong now I'd like to
take a little bit and think what would
you want to do as white some of the
options to think about are you are going
in a very logical direction so it's it's
not going you're not gonna start
thinking you want some crazy sacrifice
it's more positional and how you would
continue from there so yeah take a
little bit of time and think how would
you want to continue as white
so what do you think it's okay how do
you want to develop your pieces as white
so you want to try and move this night
it's not a bad idea because you kind of
want to open this bishop yeah and you
see like that's why I have these pawns
on f6 and E 5 so I'm kind of blinding
your Bishop regardless so maybe if you
think about something more active with
this pawn so maybe it moves such as yeah
yeah so that was my other question well
yeah I like the d4 idea both teaching
you can play d4 right now
another move to think about is d3 so do
we have any fans for d3 d4 going once
going twice
you guys like this is alright okay so we
have one d4 taker d4 is a very nice move
and my opponent actually did play it in
the game and I was kind of I was
prepared and after the game I asked him
why did he play that and he said that he
kind of prepared it long ago and I was
like yeah I had no idea I was just going
off of my brain and yeah he actually
liked it kind of went a little deeper
than than just here but okay let's look
at d3 first
so if d3 I have the chance to think
about a move such as a four even if it
doesn't work right now a four is the
idea because my game as black is in the
queenside so you kind of want to open
that Queen side so that your rook is
active your bishops are active see like
these bishops are kind of all looking
this way are looking this way this rook
these two nights so ideally that's
something that I would want to do and
the other thing is I could have played
Queen d7 and I'm simply my queen is
simply just defending these two not that
they needed defending but my queen ante
it wasn't really doing anything in d7
least of all is kind of protecting my
pieces I really don't like hanging my
pieces so that's something that I
thought of and if Queen comes to c2 for
example you could just play rook t8 and
put more pressure on this this Center
and I didn't really go too deep in these
analysis because it kind of made sense
but these are like some ideas that could
be followed like trying to play c5 and
just gaining more
on the queenside so that's one idea
the other idea that I kind of followed
was after d4 mmm I don't want to give up
the move let's think about the move a
little bit now think about it for black
what can black do what should black do
oh I do have access to live chats by the
way I might not look at it like all the
time but I will keep checking at it time
to time all right let's see
okay but we are only talking about it
takes T for do it why only takes T for
it takes 2 4 is pretty obvious night
comes to be 5 and why it's kind of
getting that pawn back so I'm talking
about if I take here
nice girls to be 5 and then just there's
no way I can hold this pawn so
theoretically I could go for something
maybe like d3 just to mess up with
White's pawn structure a little bit but
it takes d4 is not the only move so what
are what else
yeah and I fixed a four makes sense
right because if you were to play Knight
takes d4 your opponent can't play this
95 anymore but what you have to be
careful is when this Knight moves and
this Knight also moves this pawn will be
weak so now you have to kind of think
about it does 94 actually make sense
like is it playable
okay so 94 does kind of make sense and
works because if the night takes it
takes d4 and Bishop e7 doesn't work
because first of all you could think
about and move such as take and for
example take here just simply take this
Bishop and neither secondary can the
bishop but also if Bishop takes p7 you
kind of loops if Bishop takes p7 you
could also simply play rook b8 if you
don't really want to calculate and
you're attacking the bishop and the
night so you are gonna pick some stuff
up yeah so myself but Mateo yeah he is
right you can't take you're not wrong
and so Knight takes the and if here
Knight d5 is poised so Knight takes d4
Knight takes d4 takes with the pawn and
now Knight d5 what do you think now
before you answer to let's think about
what is different with ninety five here
and ninety five here so the only thing
that's kind of different is that these
two knights are on the board right so
the one way that you could think about
it is now that the Knights are not on
the board was this like what what
difference does it make does it open up
something for black what is open up for
white
yes that is true
for white the diagonal is open and this
pawn these two pawns are under direct
attack compared to here when this night
was kind of protecting these two so what
is different for black what advantage
does black have
how you are right when how
so you are right what black could have
better control of center but what move
are you thinking yes
six
c6 is you have to write pawn to move but
little short on squares c6 is nice but
white will just take this and now white
is also White's to Bishop but I kind of
opened up not completely but your
bishops are also kind of hanging here
they're not really doing anything so c5
was the move that I wanted to do and if
takes just root be eight and the
difference is that now this black is the
one who's controlling the center so you
had the right idea of controlling the
center and now also the this Knights
kind of hanging so there could be some
jumping stuff or a fours or just a lot
of possibilities so in the game after it
takes d4 and my opponents didn't play
Knight d5 and he played Knight e4 now
this pawn is still hanging I don't I
can't play c5 anymore cuz just take and
realistically you can't really save the
pun so what do you think you should do
as black
so do you wanted to send that to
mess up destruction
do you think you can defend upon
ok so we have some suggestions online
about d3 or f5 okay we have more d3 yeah
d3 is actually the move that I played in
the game because I kind of well f5 is
interesting but the problem is that even
after f5 there are a lot of weaknesses
least of all this night comes to c5
still attacking my pawn and now my
bishop and now this pawn I didn't really
see how to keep keep it all in order
because even if I take drug takes still
same problem pawn under attack pawn
under attack and if I don't take it and
play something like Bishop d5 I think
least of all which just could go like
this
I think that's or just even taking with
the Queen just simply the simplest moves
and I still lose upon so there's kind of
no way for me to actually keep the pawn
exactly and that's why I pushed because
now if yeah now if boy like white tries
to take it like this light is not really
doing anything here maybe you want to
jump to c5 but this pawn is like already
a target
I could probably start doubling up my
heavy pieces here to attack this pawn
maybe you could also think about a move
like a four knife take you can just take
with the 19's active Bishop and then the
pawn is also under attack if not you
want to open up the stroke so you have a
lot of possibilities and that's why my
opponent didn't take in the game and
plays rooks III I take take now even
though I'm a pawn up it's still pretty I
have to be very careful because this
Bishop is kind of weak over here whoops
this pawn is weak over here so White's
next move could be something like night
c5 so knowing that yeah I am scared as
black to Paul yeah so I was but nothing
what do you do think about a move also
another thing is rook t1 could be coming
up so your queen is not safe here I've
said enough so maybe try to think about
what move you would want to do
I do like the idea of Queen CH because
you're simply protecting the bishop and
the pan so that's something that I would
think about more seriously but I think
that question is after Queen c8 what do
you think white can do because Queen see
it makes kind does make sense to play as
black but also your queen is going to c8
and then this rook is against the Queen
and still has its own problems
all right so Quincy it is the move that
I played and yeah we have some questions
about doubling the rook up maybe more
concerns and questions but like Luke c1
does make sense because rook c1 you're
simply trying to attack but c6 kind of
strengths my position up a bit
cuz now this pawn is defended this point
is defended and the only thing that 95
could be coming up or maybe even 95 here
just to save up a Tempe so my opponent
played like c5 so I think the idea was
that since the position is open since
the center is open my opponent wanted to
try and exploit the idea of like how to
bishops like open center which is kind
of cliche but it's also true so probably
that's why my opponent did that and I
completely agree with it I would have
done the same if I were white and that
idea is not c5 so after Knight c5 I
missed I I missed finding the best move
on the board
so think about intermediate moves
this is kind of not easy at first glance
and that's kind of why and the game I
also didn't find it but it is kind of
interesting so let's try to find it
be careful because this bishop could be
taken with check
yeah
Bishop 65 is the move that I played in
the game and it is a good move but it's
not the best one visual trick c5 is kind
of the most straightforward one and
there's nothing wrong with straight
forward but I'm trying to see if anybody
is seeing the move I haven't seen it yet
so okay the way to think about it is all
right so this light is kind of annoying
over here attacking your Bishop and this
pawn is falling so you have two options
either you have to take it or you have
to come up with something super smart
a little too crazy so the thing is you
don't mm-hmm I don't want to give up the
north I'll just say the move is with
this bishop but not the squares that
I've heard so far okay so not Bishop g4c
not Bishop c4 or f7 I also be careful
when you move this bishop like if you go
to f5 queenie 527 so
no Platt Bishop g4 why everybody likes
Bishop g4 okay ah i'll wait for nope not
Bishop c4 I'll wait for another 30
seconds and then I'll just say it
because I've already said the movies
with this bishop and you're kind of
running out of squares
tink when this bishop is not here and
this Queen is over here this Queen and
this work could be in the fork ideally
but you can't do that yes I got well I
mean I kind of hurt all the squares but
yeah Bishop d5 is the move that I should
have played night Queen takes e7 you can
just simply take here and play 95 and if
like the Queen can only pretty much play
like Queenie six because now like we
would enter something like this or I
could just try and wait hold on I do
have to take but now my rook is under
attack
oh yeah I could just play something like
rook e8 or yeah so I assume that Bishop
h3 also works by the same logic but I
think the problem is with Bishop e7 like
if you wanted to just open up something
for the exchange off the bishops and
open up the d5 square the Bishop h3
logic works but this should be 7 I don't
think it's that pretty for black so
Quincy 895 this doctor comes to deef
Bishop should have came to d5 now if
Queen takes you can just take this guy
and play 95 the thing is well with
fork-like white could try to save the
queen but I am pretty sure I can just
take on c3 and then just b6 and I have
it's a rookie on one con against this
two pieces not a not as ideal as you
would want so that's kind of why
probably my brain wasn't really thinking
about who's in the game because who
wants to give up to these two pieces for
one group
so yeah Bishop takes if I was also a
very nice normal move but well it would
have been I awesome if for me if like if
I just took it back immediately but
that's not the move that's why it's
played and logically because there is an
intermediate move so think about what
this intermediate move is this part of
the game was kind of a little like I
take this you can't take that tapped at
that so you had to really keep an eye on
what was on your attack like because I'm
upon up so if white just for his simple
moves I had the upper hand and I had
advantage so white kind of had to come
up with so these like supposedly crazy
ideas
so think about takes and think about
what stuff are hanging but I'll tell you
right now rook takes if I was not the
right move
so what do you think ism
okay so let's think about it like this
the pieces that are kinda under attack
are DS whoops right
that's potential for attacking for white
so rook c5 is one of it but it's kind of
super straightforward and if rooks e6
I'm pretty sure I can just play c6 and I
have one more pawn so the move that you
should talk about is take on b7 let's
see okay so we have some people who
suggested Bishop takes b7 and the idea
is well if you take Queen to xb7 simply
Queen takes e6 you move this guy rook
takes e5 now you're you gave back the
pawn and now the material is equal and
this these pawns these pawn structures
are kind of a little sucky and also
white pieces are very active so the idea
is that if you were to straight forward
take it but in chess we kind of ideally
try to train ourselves to think about
checks first so find me check I guess
it's like a lot about intermediate news
because Bishop takes b7 your immediate
response is kind of take it back but you
can't because it's not the best move
it's kind of a pretty bad move so you
have to come up with the intermediate
moves so what is that intermediate move
yes
ok so we have some people finding the
move yeah Bishop Lee - Bishop takes f2
is the right move because Bishop takes
f2 is pretty much the only move that
keeps you in the game because if Queen
takes b7
it's simply you're simply Wars and now
the black is the one kind of fighting -
mmm equal the position so Bishop takes
up two rook takes f2 you could take the
bishop back take the bishop back King is
eight now ideally for white white kind
of wants to keep this keep this edge up
because the point is that if it's black
to move again black could try and play
something like 95 this rook is not doing
anything here so rook e8 maybe district
comes to d8 maybe this pawn if this
night is on d5 the knight is also kind
of protecting this pawn so like Black
has these ideas so for white it is best
to try and take out the one piece of
black that is kind of hiding but it's
strong so this this Queen is hiding but
it's very strong see it's in this
diagonal if Y black could play recruit
e8 maybe rookie d1 but I could try and
organize an attack and that is why my
opponent who was a grandmaster I forgot
to say that played queen c6 and you know
like we've always heard if you're a
piece if you're a material down don't
try to exchange pieces don't really go
down to end games like try to keep the
game live but in this specific situation
or like there are situations that's
generally
that idea that if you have more material
exchanged stuff up and go to endgame is
right but in this specific situation
Chris Isaak's was the move that the
position needed because after Queen c6 I
do have to take it and now white kind of
has compensation and what has really
nice ideas to keep pressuring my
participant this pawn and white is way
more active so yeah the way the game
followed was I could have thought about
rook f7 but I thought it's really
passive and I really really want this
night to just do something instead of
being dead over here
so I played 95 now what do you think
white should do keep in mind that rook
c2 doesn't work cause of 94 that was
another little little trick that I
opened so
what do you think what should do
yeah
um
be careful cuz it is well defended you
what you could think about is district
essentially doing anything right now so
try to activate these keys
okay yeah we have suggestions with drug
t to maybe Bishop D for Bishop to a tree
yeah I like these ideas so you kind of
wanna try and I don't like I don't
really understand Bishop III because
Bishop III even though you're like
temporarily not letting night before I
could just play something like rook f7
or just play rook c8 then keep this pawn
and now I want to play night before and
like even if rook c2 you're not really
attacking this pawn so I could probably
even just play rook d8 and this night
here is very strong protecting
everything so you do have to play rook
d2 so if rook t2 now 94 works kind of
because if you were to play like rook t8
there might be this rook c5 that keep
attacking your Knights now you do have
to move the knight and regardless of
where you go your c7 pound falls so I
don't think Brooke th is a bad move but
probably not the most accurate one so 94
you're willingly giving up c7 both
you're taking a two in return it does
look a little bit sketchy to be honest
but since my knight can come back to
before anytime I want
it's not as scary if Bishop e3 you can
just play 94 and the rook endgame is
most likely going to be a draw if white
tries to push way too hard there could
like let's say White's tries to play
rook to e4 I could just simply play or
okay a one or I could just play route
comes to piece f b8 if you play rook c4
keep attacking my pawn then I could just
probably give your check you
you check and even though this pond
would fall the rookie and game is still
a draw you just have to be careful not
to get made it over here because of your
weak back rank so that's why Bishop Eric
wasn't really played rook d7 it is kind
of again cliche that we've always heard
that looks like the seventh rank but
it's also true rooks are very strong on
the seventh rank now you are attacking
this pawn you might have ideas to trick
a seven so how do you want to continue
as black keep in mind that rook g8 does
not work first of all wasn't why doesn't
your g8 work now you can think about
getting a little sacrifice II
so what is the move you're thinking
about
see
this King here kind of feels a little
suffocated right so how can we do eyes
try and exploit it
okay
yeah see the problem is Bishop takes f6
and if you try to take it back
bye-bye so it is rook she doesn't work
so after they okay it doesn't work you
have to start thinking about how well
you can't just let white start roaming
around in your seventh-ranked so how can
you try to activate your pieces rook
Jade doesn't work so we play rook b8
especially because you ideally you would
want to trade off one of these rooks so
that white doesn't have as a strong as a
grip on the 7th rank and again my
opponent played rock g7 but he kind of
should've played rook a 7 and the idea
is really 7 if I take this guy
oops mate if I take this guy same
problem so root comes to here now the
next move could even be something like
root K 5 whoops so I have to try and
save my king with a move such as h5 and
now this pawn goes and this endgame is a
still draw but I'm the one who has to
kind of be very careful and suffer and
all of those fun stuff so in the game
route g7 made my life a little bit
easier cuz check and well terrifically
wise could have given a perpetual now
but white kind of thoughts that because
this pawn is passed pawn this pawn could
become something big
now do you think after soaking it does
have to go to g2 now this is kind of
another critical position because some
of them moves actually lose and you kind
of only have few moves that keeps you
the draw so take a little bit of time
and find these final moves it is black -
yep
Oh Thank You Cesar
I've actually never had online I'm not a
very big online streamer so we've never
gotten that much for a lecture oh well
thank you I like to set records
okay let's see people in the chat are
thinking about we have a move Knight c3
actually I did think about the move
Knight feature in the game not the not
the move you should be thinking about
just a tip but so be careful because
okay let's see why Knight c3 is wrong
then maybe it will help us find the
right Smoove so if Knight c3 oops why
it's just pushes now if you try to bring
your knight
it's a little too late because ideally
white wants to get to this position now
white wants to kind of meet you so you
could try to give like check here and
maybe another like check here and try to
you know get something out of the game
but the problem is just King e1 and this
if this a 5-pound wasn't here then you
know it was awesome because I could just
play rook e1 and win but I can't and so
yeah that is a problem so this is what
white wants to get at white wants to
have that plan on h6 give a check on g7
push my King to go to f8 and try to play
rook h8 mate we have a question about my
rook no rook g3 yeah because okay so
here you can't yeah you can't really
play rook g3 because now my king is kind
of a little freer I'm actually probably
check check check because
hold on what is the good news with rook
g3
oh yeah the problem is that simply there
is no more mate so I can just play rook
e8
or even rook b8 a pretty pretty much
let's put the rook to b8 so have them
both kind of safe and if you give a
check this is still a little scary but
it's not mate and it is dropped and if
you try to bring your rook back now I
can try to give a check and try to give
you another check and I don't really see
how white can be saved so that is the
problem with Knight c3 now that we know
what what white whoops going way to back
now that we know what white wants think
about how black can try to prevent it
remember white ideally wants to have
this pawn on
h6 give a check over here and then mate
you so that the spawn on h6 is
controlling the g7 rook so
I'll give it another minute and then
I'll just tell them move because it is
very interesting but I I know my games
are very interesting but we have to get
to one close game
okay so what I thought about in the game
even though it was good there were other
moves that could have worked but maybe
just not as simple so my idea was that
if this pawn wants to come to h6 and
this rooks want to come to g7 if I have
something that's defending this square
for example let's imagine in that I play
route B 5 and now if rook g7 whoops now
if you play like h5 I could just play
rook g5 if h6 well rook g7 doesn't work
anymore so that's kind of why my
opponent wrapped up the game by check
check check and he ended in a draw but
the problem was that if I were to play
Knight c3 that rook wouldn't get there
in time
another move that I could have done but
I didn't really seen the game was f5 now
h5 I could give a check and now bring
the rook should be 6 because again if h6
I have this rook g6 so another thing is
if white tries to give the check first
and then play h6 we could take this guy
and now I'm just a piece up and upon so
the idea is that white can't really play
this theoretically white still well it's
check but for example in this situation
with rook b5 if white were to play check
first and then h5 I could just play
through g5 or I could take on h5 now if
you take I just take this rook so
probably here my opponents would have
started to give some check but now it's
not draw anymore so
yeah oh okay
so the problem so now we know the
problem is we know the ideas and we know
how the game ended just a quick recap so
what does white one
white wants to have white wants to have
that pawn on h4 on h6 this rook to g7
and giving me so the next few moves that
I do should be about getting some piece
to defend my King and simply having my
knight come to see troops simply having
my knight to come to C 3 and E 4 isn't
enough because my knight doesn't get
there in time to stop the attack so I
need to have a rook near my king so I
could either achieve that the drip B 5
and then rook g5 or I could achieve that
whoops with f5 and then rook p6 maybe
rook g6 or just to control over here so
that was the idea and I played Ruby 5
and this is how the game ended well this
was pretty fun I hope you enjoyed it we
did have a lot of interesting ideas in
chat it is not very easy to find these
kind of moves especially over the boards
when you just feel like oh my god I've
blundered something now mate so yeah I
hope you tune in for the game of the
week which probably up starts in about
five minutes
so yeah until next time
you
[Music]